thank you okay so this is the first part
of the tutorial so acknowledgments
disclaimers and you know the most
important things so this is based on
collaborative works that I have done
with my students at UT and USC Facebook
collaborators especially the system's
part that that motivates the the
technically the technological irrelevant
questions that we've been recently
looking at so also we vacanze ack who
have been collaborators and also you
know I call them every now and then I
say hey is this still open has it been a
recent paper that I'm missing and all
that my advisors of course who I worked
on these problems and neha didn't rush
me who are here and Berkeley who work on
this and the organizers for inviting me
of course now a disclaimer is I try to I
will try to focus a lot on open problems
and what is what is not known in this
area and the problem is that this is
actively evolving so if i miss something
that that you know is not open and and i
think it is please let me know okay now
there's two parts in this tutorial the
first one i will focus on on
regenerating codes and this is this is
what i will do today and the second part
i will focus on on other things that we
have been doing including locality that
that work should i gave a very nice
tutorial before but i will basically go
go over a few things a little
differently and then some some
extensions of locality that we call
availability and and release and work
actually with collaboration with with
anna who's here on on badge codes so
this is the second part for for tomorrow
okay so this is my motivation sort of
slide this is an actual trace from
facebook cluster that has three thousand
machine so this is a Hadoop cluster that
stores analytics data so it's not a
front facing cluster that you interact
with as a customer but rather in the
back end and the important thing to
notice here is those were three thousand
machines and this is a trace of how many
machines were failing at any given time
now failing you have to define exactly
what you mean by failing it's not that
you know it exploded necessarily that it
could be that that the machine was just
unavailable for for for 20 minutes or or
or you know a few hours which is still a
problem if you try to read the data that
is in that machine so this is like the
issue of a like currently available
versus actual failure of data now the
thing to look here is that you could
have as many as 100 machines failing in
a day in a bad day okay now a machine in
this specific cluster was strolling
typically around 15 terabytes 10 to 15
terabytes of data those were pretty big
machines so if you have a machine that
that has crashed and you you have to
recreate the information that was lost
in that machine and the main point that
that kind of is who should be motivated
about is that if you have 20 notes that
are down in a given day and that's a
pretty good day if you see this like
because 22 is here so most days you have
more than 22 then you have you have
approximately 300 terabytes of lost data
that you need to repair and if you use
it it Soloman coding as as I will
explain in a second for every bit that
you lose if you repair you have to pay
specifically Solomon that that they're
using here you have to do 10 X so for
every bit you lose you have to
communicate 10 times that to repair that
one bit I will explain what repair means
in a second but I'm just giving you the
motivation so there's a ridiculous
amount of communication that happens to
happen in the cluster to repair the data
that is lost I will I will define what I
mean which is motivating it here so we
estimate that thirty percent maybe of
the network traffic in this class there
is two fold yes
a couple of hours why would you repair
things if it's okay so if it is very
good so most it depends not all of it is
is for a couple of hours some of it is
for so the real world is complicated now
if it's if it's being decommissioned as
they say then they need to repair it
even if it is on of it so is that it
that's one case where they need to
repair another case where they need to
repair is if it is unavailable but
someone still wants to read the data so
that's the degraded read which is this
Sam please like you know 300 turbines
giving birth to the size of the cluster
right so the question is how often
queries will try to read this data and
in fact as far as I understand and
emphatic [ __ ] can tell us more but the
main reason that people motivate this is
in current clusters in analytics is the
degraded raid so it is things that you
try to read data that is currently not
the server that stores the systemic
block is not available right now and you
still want to read it you issue a repair
job that is not to deconstruct 44 fault
tolerance but rather for performance of
a query yeah so but in reality that's
that's a real bottleneck okay so that's
why it's Solomon codes are not suitable
and that's why Microsoft and others are
switching to using model distributed
storage codes so ok now let's let's go
in theory land and and explain exactly
what what we mean ok now a storing stuff
with linear equations so when I say so I
will draw pictures like this right and I
say some some node I will call them
storage nodes like machines some notes
there's a some notes there's be some
noise source of parity etc now when I
say that a node stores a let us go back
here let's say you do nothing about
coding theory in fact I throughout the
talk you don't need to know coding
theory you need to know linear algebra
ok so I'll just do everything linear
algebra wait ok linear algebra is when I
say somebody stores a it's a stores
somewhere says a is three ok and we can
think of arithmetic modulo prime if you
want or just normal arithmetic is fine
too except
very few parts of the top so when you
start a is three in one machine and you
start b is 1 in another machine and then
another you store a plus B is for so I
you store the linear equation and the
output of the linear equation right so
this is for example a very simple code a
4 comma to code and it contains to
systematic symbols that is a and B these
two numbers here and these for linear
equations that you're storing in these
two numbers and the generator matrix of
the code is this k by n matrix and it
has this nice property as you as you can
see that if you lose any two out of
these four storage nodes you can
reconstruct the data right so for
example and i just realized i can do
this in powerpoint observe I can do this
I can go here and I say now you lose
this and you lose this ok so now and
when you actually lose them what you
really lose is really this stuff right
so you don't know this one you know that
you had a note that was storing and B
but you don't you don't know the 4 and
the 3 and of course this will be very
big right this will be in the megabytes
so don't think of it as actually smaller
ok so now you've lost two things if we
go can you reconstruct of course you can
because you have two linear equations
that have ranked two if we look at it in
the generator matrix so this here's the
generator matrix so you lost this column
and you lost this column and the reason
you can reconstruct is because this
matrix has all its square sub matrices
that are foreign right so that's great
so an MDS code as it's called is a k by
n matrix that has the nice property that
all its square sub matrices are full
rack ok and now if you don't know
anything about continues okay how hard
can that be right but just randomly
choose numbers you know I'll get the
matrix where all the squares amedisys
will be full rank but it's not that easy
in a finite field all right so did
Solomon codes is an explicit way of
constructing matrices that have the
problem all it's all the squares are
made this is alpha rank in a small field
is that the smallest field where you can
do it nobody knows
then open a famous MDS conjecture that
the smallest field where you can create
this matrix where all the squares are
matrices are Frank is that it Solomon
construction and I guess Vanka told me
there has been some recent progress on
this but it's still open in general it's
all hopeful prime fields it's okay very
good okay so everything here is is
classic very good now the only thing i
want to say here is that instead of
thinking that I store as3 think that a
is actually going to be 64 megabytes
that's how big it is in Hadoop for
example and then you store you store you
repeat the same code you know many times
right so you store across and now when
you say a plus B you XOR these and you
repeat the same code you know thousands
of times so these are very big but the
overhead of storing what is the equation
is small so we always think of the
numbers as big okay now what is repair
repair is the following very basic
problem I was actually really surprised
I I was talking with with hearing in a
fairly actually with with cs grad
student genre who who told me that this
is a problem they have in in a
peer-to-peer system where they use it
its solemn on and they lose one equation
that's the most common thing are you the
most common thing is one failure so
repair means you have a single erasure
so you don't know be and you want to
reconstruct it okay that's not the
problem we said you can tolerate any to
arrange right so you can definitely
tolerate one the issue is okay here you
want to recreate what you lost be how
much communication do you need to do in
a network to recreate what you lost this
is the repair bandwidth problems they
repair communication from how many bits
need to be communicated to reconstruct
one lost symbol is that clear because if
it's not just be very boring top okay
very good both are interesting but let's
think about any symbol for now okay so
how much communication do I need to
repair a single loss symbol for example
this really basic question I'm
embarrassed to say that for it Solomon
codes we don't know the answer
okay so let's but let's first let's
first think about a few trivial things
so the first avail thing is obviously if
you send any two symbols you can
recreate the lost symbol right okay for
example this guy which we call the
newcomer can communicate to these two
guys say hey what is a plus B this guy
would say a plus B's for this guy will
say a plus 2b is five so you send two
symbols from here you said nothing this
kind of has two linear equations in two
unknowns he can solve for B throw away a
happy times okay very easy can you do it
with less that so that was that was the
main thing we realized is that you can
actually reconstruct one symbol by
communicating less than two symbols
that's the punchline is that is that is
that surprising now I don't know the
back then it was so my claim is that I
can actually repair a single symbol with
1.5 symbols by communicating 1.5 symbols
and I will also prove to you that this
is optimal but not for it so lamont you
have to give me the power to design my
own crazy MDS code to do that okay what
the hell does it mean to communicate 1.5
symbol communicating 1.5 symbol is the
idea of what we call sub packetization
which means splitting your symbols into
half symbols and for example we'll be
doing linear equations over half symbols
and forming what we would sometimes
called vector linear operations so is
the problem clear to everyone please let
me know if it's not okay so I want to
I'm just going to do it for this 4 comma
to MDS code okay so here is the
construction that I'll use so instead of
having before we had four nodes right
and every node was stoning one linear
equation now i'm going to have one note
this one and this one node will be
storing two linear equations and then I
have split my my symbols into half
symbols ok so I have now for half
symbols x1 x2 x3 x4 and this node is
storing two of them and this note is
going to of
m and this guy starting two linear
equations to half linear equations and
this guy is starting to halfling
language now is it true that this is an
MDS code a 4 comma to MDS code well I
have to show you that if you if you lose
any two nodes for example you know maybe
you lose this node then you lose this
node you can still reconstruct all the
data and it's true here because you are
going to get for linear equations in
four unknowns okay so that's fine so
this is a 4 comma to MDS code that that
has been suffocated the packetization
level here is two ok now I lose the
first node and I need to recreate it
here the trivial thing to do would be to
send for example these two packets and
these two packets totally sending two
symbols right and i claim I can do it
with with 1.5 symbols which means i can
do it by communicating three of those
packets ok can do that another trick
that I will be doing here that we don't
know when I need to do it exactly but I
will do it in this case is if I want
these two things are co-located so I can
create a linear combination of them if I
want to locally and send that right and
I will be doing that so every I can mix
the local stuff here mix it here mix it
here and then the things i send is what
I'm paying for in this in this problem
ok so let us try something simple so I
can choose for example coefficients 1
and 1 basically effectively exploring
these two packets and create a packet x3
and x4 and give it to this guy ok now
let's understand one thing this guy
wants to solve for x1 and x2 ok he
doesn't want x3 or x4 so x3 and x4 is
jug to do the sky it's it's irrelevant
information interference so that's why I
make it red so this equation seems to be
completely useless to this guy because
it involves things he is not interested
in but it will be actually very useful
as we will see in a sec okay so i can
choose any coefficients I like to create
any local linear combination I like
is then going to be transferred in the
network and I need to transfer 30
packets daughter to match my promise to
you okay so i choose one and one and i
do this so let's try let's see this is
this going to work what do you think if
you're nothing don't know this doesn't
work so why doesn't this work what's the
problem what's happening here what do
all these symbols mean so let's look at
lot now this thing is created locally at
this node and this is communicated over
the network right okay so I am
communicating as I promised to you three
half symbols that's cool now what are
these three hubs impose these are three
linear equations okay this equation says
x3 plus x4 is 53 this one says this is
you know 50,000 or something and
something like that now this guy gets
these three linear equations these are
three linear equations in four unknowns
and you can he wants to solve for two of
them unfortunately if I give you three
linear equations in four unknowns you
cannot solve for two of them right okay
in fact these three linear equations
cannot be solved for X 1 X 2 and now
maybe you can see the trick that I'm
going to do I'm going to massage this
linear equations in a way that that they
are solvable for x1 and x2 so how can I
do that there are many ways so that so
the power I have is choosing these
coefficients right okay so what I need
to do is I need to make sure that the
undesirable stuff is cancellable right
okay so this is this is the idea of
interference alignment exactly so
interference is this subspace that is
undesired and I need to make sure that
it appears with the same coefficients in
these two equations so if I if I could
make these coefficients for example 11
and 11 then I could use this linear
equation to cancel out the undesired
stuff in the other two and this guy
would be very happy he would be able to
solve for the things he want and the way
that what we did it so we realize this
in 2009
with you now know that if we choose this
coefficient to be the inverse of this
and this coefficient to be the inverse
of this we have aligned the interference
to this one and then here we can set it
to be whatever we wanted so that you can
use this linear equation to cancel out
these two and recover the desired symbol
okay so this is a interference alignment
three equations in four variables that
are solvable for two of the unknowns
okay so now I was able to to repair a 4
comma 2 code by communicating for como
to MDS code because it's this little MDS
code by communicating 1.5 symbols as i
promised to you and there are a few
questions now that that are obvious the
first one is okay what about a 5-2 code
or a 53 code or any other code what's
the minimum repair communication ah and
for this question we did not know if you
can do this trick already the moment you
add you add another symbol here
systematic symbol you will not have
enough power in your coefficients to
alive so there's a baby version of
interference alignment here where you
say okay how many linear alignments do i
need this many how many coefficients do
I have to choose stuff from this many
okay do I have enough degrees of freedom
to make it work and that only works for
very few cases and these are the cases
that we discovered but there are other
papers in in the fence alignment
starting from Konami jafar and can
Danny's work that that was shown that
you could align way more stuff if you
were careful about designing your
original code in the right way and we do
not know how to use that technique in
general but then then other people who
did we're able to solve this problem in
general so right now there are ways for
any n comma k code to to design that
code in a way that you match the optimal
repair communication I will talk about
that in a second these are called MSR
code and it doesn't start from Microsoft
Research it stands for minimum storage
regenerating codes
problem is that they are not practical
they require so you see what I did here
is I split a packet into two things that
I call sub packets in general we need to
split into a ridiculous number that I
think in the first works was doubly
exponential right now the state of the
art is exponential and we basically
don't know if we can do it in a
polynomial sub packetization the field
size we need is also exponential so
basically we have codes that are MDS and
are optimally repairable but we don't
have practical and MDS regenerating
codes to the best of my understanding
right now so we'll talk about that a
little bit more so the so the lower
bound is is through the information flow
graph the cut-set bound is that what oh
for the field size so that is there is
work on this work on lower bounding the
field size and his work on lower
bounding sub packetization so if you
limit yourself I'll talk about it yeah
but very good yeah there are some lower
bounds but they're not true they're not
valid in general they have some
limitations to the best of my
understanding okay so we understand the
problem right okay so cool so let me let
me tell you a little bit about how we
can prove the lower bound in
communication so maybe you could do less
than 1.5 symbols right maybe you could
do point five symbols that's that's
clearly not possible because at the end
of the day you will create one symbol so
you better communicate one symbol but
maybe one symbol is achievable okay so
we started in a for Kamata code 1.5
symbol surfaces I will show that this is
also necessary and I will use a flow
argument ok what's the flow argument so
this is the thing I lost this is the new
comer and this newcomer is going to
connect to the existing storage nodes
and download better bits from each of
the existing storage nodes observe that
I'm choosing here the symmetric point
where you download better from each if
you understand this proof you will be
able to very quickly proved yourself
that the symmetric point is actually the
best point alright so let's understand
how to how to give a lower bound on
better ok
so first I add a virtual super source
where every all the information in the
universe originates okay i connect the
super source with links of capacity
infinity to those now I'm doing this
trick where I split every storage node
in two parts and I put this green arrow
which is how much how much information
is stored in this storage node so this
is the storage node today this is the
storage node tomorrow and this represent
storage this link here and then I said
well this newcomer communicated with the
three surviving nodes and downloaded
better bits from each that's fine the
capacity here is one so I say one
megabyte I mean one symbol just think of
it that way okay and now i'm putting
this guy that I call a data collector
what's the data collector i did a
collector corresponds to remember what
are we trying to do we need this these
three symbols and the new symbol to form
a 4 comma to MDS code that means that
any two out of these four must give me
all my data somebody's calling it's not
a good time so as any to must give me
all the data right so let's choose the
this specific set of to this specific
set of two must have enough information
to reconstruct all the data so I claim
that there must be enough flow from the
source of all the information to this
guy how much flow do I need I need all
the data which in this case is two
symbols right so if i find a cut
separating the source to this data
collector that is smaller than two
symbols it's clearly impossible that i
have repaired this this node so this is
the argument is this is this clear okay
so now i'm going to find a cut that
separates the source to this data
collector and i'm going to cut this edge
the capacity of this edge is one symbol
and i'm going to cut these two and first
of all you see that this is a cut
there's no way to travel from the source
to this data collector without going
through these three edges and now the
capacitive this is one the capacitive
this is better and better I'm trying to
I'm trying to give a bound on those so
the value of the cut is one plus two
better
and 1 plus 2 beta has to be bigger than
the total amount of information which is
too therefore you get that better has to
be greater than one-half okay I'll prove
I'll just say the same thing yes so have
to be the same very good so they don't
have to be the same but if they are
different better 1 beta 2 beta 3 I can
choose a set of two nodes remember any
two out of the four must keep must me
give me the data back right so you
choose any better as you want i will
choose the two smallest ones and put
them in the cut and i will get that any
to bust up be greater or equal to 2 and
i will get that the sum of them is
minimized in the symmetric case exactly
so so you can prove that the symmetric
is the minimizing the sum of the repair
communication okay another way of saying
this going back here is ok let us go
back here I'll just say the same thing
in a different way remember we're trying
to create hear something so that any two
out of these four recreate the data
right the data is two megabytes ok now
let's take these two these two must know
everything about the data but this guy
got everything he learned from here
you're already getting from here so this
is useless and this is one megabyte
you're getting from here so this
information better be one megabyte also
right that's exactly the same thing as
what I said before I'm just telling you
the same argument in another way ok so
that's how you can prove that the repair
communication must be greater than
one-half now another thing that that is
important here is that we can relax make
a little relaxation to the repair
problem we can say instead of recreating
exactly the linear equation that was
lost I can take a step back and say okay
you know what don't recreate exactly
their linear question you lost create a
new linear equation that just has the
property that is in general position
compared to the others which means that
you just created a new MDS code now so
you change the code but it's still MDS
which means that any two out of these
new four equations
our full rack now if you can if you
could do that that is called functional
repair and it's an easier problem than
exact repair and the question is what is
the minimum amount of communication to
do functional repair so in the first
paper that we did which was basically
the main paper my dissertation we were
able to completely characterize the
repair communication for functional
repair and the reason is understanding
that functional understanding this case
this graph that looks complicated that
says that functional repair is really
multi casting and nothing more okay now
what what does that mean what is so an
MDS code so I'll just maybe i'll just
write something here so a 4 comma to MDS
code is this so this is the source and
these are four symbols and and the four
comma to MDS code means that any two out
of these four symbols allow you to
reconstruct your data right so we can
view this as a multi casting problem
where I put a data collector for these
two and the data collector for these two
and you get the idea right so for any
two so I'm going to put 4 choose 2 data
collectors which correspond to all
possible failure patterns and an MDS
code is simply a way to create linear
equations that travel through this graph
that satisfy all these 4 choose 2 ways
of reconstructing the data right okay so
that is a multi casting problem and now
there's two two arguments that we're
using here the first one is that if
there is a single data collector a
single sink that doesn't have enough
flow to the source then you're
definitely screwed there's definitely no
way to do it but if you want
simultaneously to satisfy all these guys
with the same linear equations are you
guaranteed that there is a code if each
one individually
has sufficient flow that is true but
highly non-trivial right so that is that
is basically the than the network coding
multi casting theorem that generalizes
max-flow min-cut that says that if
you're sending the same information to
multiple receivers if the minim of them
in cuts satisfied there is a way to
satisfy all of them simultaneously and
furthermore it's very easy all you need
is general position so just randomly
choose linear equations in a big field
and by sponsible you're happy okay so a
functional repair is is exactly
equivalent to multi casting on this
graph that I call the information
information flow graph and let's see how
so the issue that that we need to worry
about it so now you this graph is
exactly this graph that I was drawing
here but in addition I had a failure so
now I'm connecting and making the
newcomer who connects and downloads
better the bits from each and I'm I
added all the fortress two data
collectors connecting to the three
surviving storage nodes and the newcomer
okay and as long as the minimum cut
separating this source to all of them is
sufficient then I know that there is a
code and furthermore just random linear
combinations will suffice and the
problem is of course this code will be
changing these linear equations here
will not be the same as these linear
equations here they will be changing so
that's why it's functional repair okay
furthermore you can think of a more
general problem where okay maybe this
node failed and I repaired it but maybe
this node failed and now I repair it
somewhere and maybe this not failed and
I debated so you can think of all sorts
of stuff that can happen right so in
order to be guaranteed that you have
enough flow you need to create all
possible failure patterns to infinity
connect them and find the minimum cut in
this infinite graph so that that's what
that's what we basically did so I'll
show you that in a second
okay so the first statement is that if
you care about functional repair it is
possible to repair to functionally
repair and MDS code by communicating
this many bits as opposed to the knife
scheme which was communicating the whole
the data object which was case symbols
okay so here the size of a symbol is be
over KB is the total size of the file
you are your story so in this paper we
were able to characterize the functional
repair communication and I mean this is
an example if each of your blocks is 64
megabytes which is what is done in
Hadoop and you just have a 4 comma 6
code the naive repair communication will
be 256 megabytes whereas if you have
optimal repair communication will be 160
so even for very small case you can get
substantial benefit and I simpatica Lee
it's even more interesting because it
scales completely differently right it
scales like order in the order of one
symbol as opposed to the order of K
symbols so there is a very big gap
between naive and and optimal okay
furthermore the other thing we realized
but then is that you can if you increase
the storage per node a little bit so you
give me a few extra bits in each note
you make your symbols a little fatter
but you still you still want to recover
from any K symbols so this now you're no
longer an MDS code then you're going to
get much better in repair communication
so there was a trade of between repair
communication and storage and the way
that this is computed is through this
infinite graph that i mentioned vary a
little bit before so here is the graph
you have the source of all everything in
the universe these are your original and
storage nodes every storage node stores
alpha bits before if your file was be
alpha was be over kick right so you were
you were storing that's that's an MDS
code okay but now I'm going to allow you
to be a little bit over that if you want
and now you have some failure any
failure I don't know and you you
introduce a new storage node that has
degree D this is how many
the existing notes he connects to and
downloads better bits from each of them
and you could be analyzing the non
symmetric issue but let's worry about
the symmetric for now so this guy is
going to connect somewhere here and then
maybe there's another failure so you
have a new repair and maybe this
connects to the newcomer and some other
people and another failure so this all
possible things that can happen will
form an infinite graph here and now what
do you want from this infinite graph
what you want is that any K things in
this process so you choose any K nodes
you want like this one this one this one
and you put a data collector and you
these links have capacity infinity and
you need to make sure that the flow or
the min cut from the source to this data
collector is bigger than than the file
you're storing and you need this for all
infinitely many data collectors ok so
the game we're playing here is that in
this infinite graph that can be formed
in any way possible I need a way to get
bound on this number this number and
this number so that the flow is
sufficiently high it exceeds the file
yes which ones you asked when you create
a new one no I am going to i'm going to
do it for any set of failures so so it
sounds complicated but it actually isn't
because you can find the worst case
failure sequence that will characterize
the cut and you can prove that any other
failure sequence will give you a bigger
so before when you showed for example
that first note they're disconnected
just to the guys word failed but now
you're connected to all right no no he
could connect in general I'm going to do
this for any degree D any repair
communication beta and any Alpha and I'm
going to create all possible failure
patterns so I could allow this to
connect to any d so these the parameter
that you're asking I guess deal in my
experience example was three yeah but
I'm goin computers for any d yeah
slightly stronger cuz let's he had one
node failure yeah it don't really care
to a coil with the new know that i done
exactly i could just be decided that i
had this and comic a code and i wanted
to go to an n plus 1 k code instead so
that's not there's no legally not really
an issue of failure here it's creating a
new symbol it's creating a new linear
question that's in general position
compared to existing linear equations so
maybe you want it maybe you had your
code then you decided i need a new lead
and and symbol but i don't have all the
data in one place i need to collect i
need to create this new linear equation
by connecting to some d other linear
equations so you could do that yes
original leather cording paper wasn't
the field size somehow function of the
size of a graph yes yes yeah so now ok
very good so now I'm in trouble so in
the in the first type where we said okay
we're only going to analyze a finite
case and we get a field size that's
exponential in the in the graph indeed
and then then there is a follower paper
where we actually show that even for the
infinite graph we can do it with a with
a finite field that doesn't scale you
use the fact that even though there's
infinitely many data collectors as
finite types of yes observed by the way
that if I was doing exactly pair none of
this business would be a problem because
the moment I have recreated this I'm
back to my previous problem right so if
I had exactly but I don't have to worry
about this but I have to worry about
much harder stuff right so okay so it
turns out that you can calculate the min
cut of this infinite graph and from this
min cut you're going to get a minimum
the best the best choices of parameters
alphabet ND you're basically finding a
cut in this in this graph and so this is
the main theorem that we had proven that
for any n comma k code each node stores
alphabets repairs from d existing nodes
and downloads d times better write this
is the total amount of information
communicated we call that gamma the
feasible region and is a piecewise
linear function that's complicated I
don't expect you to parse it but it's
just just piecewise linear and it looks
like this so this is
storage per node alpha this is the
bandwidth or repair communication beta
times D and the minimum storage point
the MDS point is when the storage per
node is the minimal possible remember
from any K nodes I mean I need to
deconstruct right so the minimum storage
per node is better over K so this is
this is on this this horizontal line it
doesn't get any better now so MDS codes
live on this line and the question I was
asking before is how sorry what am I
doing here yes storage is here so the
question is how much can you push in
this direction how small can you make
repair communication right yeah the
scale on the y-axis is in units of the
original source size so the the scale is
ok so it seems like you've got a table 5
so 0.2 yeah all right right so this is
one-fifth exactly yeah but will be over
K yes I'm sorry you're right i meant be
over k because the greek uppercase B
he's also called better very good yeah
okay so yes so this is one-fifth and
this is a kk k equals 5 course so this
is this is the MDS and the question of
what is the minimum storage point is how
much can you make how small can you make
repair communication while staying MDS
and for example for the 4 comma 2 case
we said that it's 1.5 in general we have
a formula for it but we have we need to
construct the code in a very painful way
to match it okay good so now this is the
region for functional repair and
everything outside this region
functional repair is impossible because
I show the cut-set part right so its
information theoretically impossible so
this is also called the cut-set region
yes yes please yes equals n minus 1
how does it changes you reduce d very
good so the other question we asked is
well maybe if you talk to more people
you're getting pure stuff from each but
it wasn't clear how the tension between
repair communication behaves if you if
you if you you know look at this you can
prove that these n minus 1 is the case
that minimizes repair communication so
the best thing to do if you want to
minimize the power communication is talk
to everyone who survived and download a
little bit from each that and that
that's the that's provable by the
cut-set everything i'm saying is for
functional repair and the real question
that we wanted to solve is exact repair
right so furthermore now i need to
enforce that the lost equation is equal
to the new equation that was lost and of
course the exact repair region is
something inside this but but we don't
know where it is so this was a question
we have been working on for the past I
don't know five six years now so i'll
tell you the story okay so initially we
discovered this 4 comma 2 example that I
showed you that was surprising to me
that said that Oh even 4 4 4 comma to
MDS code you can do better than than the
naive thing with exact repair and then
rush me san kumar i guess HUD so the
first papers here where they showed that
for this point which is called minimum
bandwidth free general code MBR which
allows me to store a little bit more per
node you can match the cut-set so they
created a code for this case that's very
beautiful combinatorial construction
this is this is 2011 and then there was
a sequence of papers in two thousand up
to 2012 by oles people including my
group and the berkeley group the pier
kumar's group and UT Austin surrounds
group that were able to construct codes
for for the minimum storage point
initially we had good codes for rates up
to one-half and then there was a paper
that using their fierce alignment that
was able to show it for all codes but
if these packetization being exponential
and still we don't know how to achieve
this point with with polynomial so
packetization okay so then you see now
this is this red thing is starting to
approach the blue thing and you're
saying okay I can you know I can I can
conjecture that the whole cut-set region
is achievable for exact repair and I did
conjecture that AA and and I i was
actually offering 12 bottles of ouzo in
improving or disproving that that you
know the exact repair region matches the
cut-set bound and and shot ian was there
was another AT&T actually disproved it
and he disproved with with a very
interesting proof that takes the Shannon
inequalities the polytope defined by the
mutual information greater or equal to 0
inequalities which are exponentially
many of course in a computer-assisted
proof and he was able to demonstrate an
inequality that slices through the cuts
at region and in fact for a very small
code he was able to fully characterize
the exact repair region by finding also
a code inside here and saying that Oh
for the 43 case a very small code we
know the full exactly region and it's
different from the functional and for
that reason this is a photo of child
with with 12 bottles of wine so he
didn't want to so he said I hate ouzo as
prolly most people and and I sent him
some Greek wine instead so okay but but
you see and now i will just mention some
open problems and we have a little bit
of time and you know so the first open
problem the biggest one is what is the
exact repair region right so this has
been open for a while now we know that
it's not the cut-set region the the
original proof insurance paper i don't
really pass it very well i mean it's
it's basically okay the polytope is like
you know 50 inequalities from the
polytope massage massages them in some
very interesting ways to because even
even the it
for that case without massaging them i
think it was intractable so he had to
find some symmetries to make the to make
a tractable think that he would feed in
the in a computer program so also i
think it's the first computer assisted
proof in information theory that is not
too proven in a quality but rather to
for an engineering problem so still it's
open and and it's very interesting i
guess we don't even know if Shannon if
we need not Shannon type inequalities to
characterize the exactly region so
that's probably the biggest open problem
in the area for generating codes so he
didn't use functional ok so again the
best of my understanding it's it's only
Shannon inequalities in his in his proof
so the and for that he says that for the
four three called Shannon equalities
alone are sufficient to characterize the
exact repair region and the exact type a
region is not what you get just by
computing the cuts because what the way
I got the blue thing is i computed all
the cuts in this infinite graph so the
butt but that's not the case in his yes
the red region to some electric region
or yeah so of course I mean any any
problem information theory you can you
can characterize it as so if you want
you can you can write I mean I think I
think these papers like that probably
most recent by Bacchus cigarette you say
you write down what you want from your
from your reconstruction so you can
write it in terms of entropies right
basically you say I need so you can do
this right so what you do is you say you
go here and you say i need the entropy
of this of the data given given the
things that this guy observes to be 0
that means you can reconstruct so
basically functional repair will have
reconstruction conditions only on these
data collectors okay and then you just
have the fundamental inequalities of
just Shannon for now now if you want
exact repair you have to also enforce
that this intermediate guys reconstruct
the same linear
a question that was stored in the thing
they were repairing that's what makes it
much harder so they basically the
statement are making in terms of Shannon
in the shampoo hope is that adding these
extra conditions the partial
reconstruction conditions changes the DD
polytope yeah that only makes sense to
me of these n minus 1 because then you
know which one you're repairing but with
D is smaller than the Minnesota how do
you know which one you occur but you
would have to choose which one yeah so
then it would be you would have to work
over all possibilities yeah which would
be even Messier actually this this looks
very difficult and it is not because the
cuts it so maybe I'll show this since I
haven't time there is a graph that there
is a simple graph that is the worst
graph that characterizes the worst cut
and and after you realize that you just
have to find the cut on that Wars graph
what is the worst graph so I'll show to
you it's it's actually very easy and
very intuitive so the worst graph is the
following thing it's what you would
expect so you have a source and you have
your n storage nodes ok now you have a
failure ok now you repair now you can
repair from any do you want so if we set
these n minus 1 we don't have to worry
about that so let's just do it for now
it doesn't matter but ok actually I
don't even need it so let us say that
you connect to some D ok and you repair
from those now you have another failure
so maybe you could have this failing or
this failing or this failing what's the
worst thing in terms of flow the worst
thing in there the flow is you kill the
oldest people ok so you always kill the
oldest people so here the oldest so you
kill this person now you repair this guy
he also has a choice that she could be
repaired from old people or from young
people and as you know young people are
less wise than old people so the worse
situation is when he when she connects
to the new comer and these folks and now
you have another failure what's the
worst failure again the
wisest right so you want to kill an old
person again and you have a newcomer and
the newcomer again should connect to the
least wise people and this and this so
this this is the graph that this is the
sequence you can prove that this
sequence produces the worst cut and
actually the proof that is not hard and
then also finding the cut in this graph
is not hard so that's that's where this
this region is obtained okay so there
and it's very intuitive right because
the older people get more flow so to
speak okay so good so that's that's the
the first open problem is is this clear
just for fun I mean these are simple no
it's it's it's it's impossible because
my eunuch wat ya oh oh yeah yeah so the
first of all just to say this there
isn't it is impossible is I need any k
to reconstruct let's oh yeah unless you
are in non symmetric okay for the
minimum bandwidth regenerating point
yeah so simple as your original for
example there is one really really nice
construction if I rush me the rush me
and her em it it's basically like you
what you do is you build and expand the
graph or or any graph that has like
large neighborhoods and you make this
the packets I if I remember correctly to
be the edges and you so the packets are
the edges cook sorry am I saying it
correctly okay can you remind me the is
it a complete graph that you know it's
what was I good you like a pig graph or
get more children especially right so
solly my guests had some later right
right yeah so there are some very
confident very very nice purely
combinatorial constructions where you
stop the things you store our edges in a
graph and you the nodes of storage are
the vertices in the graph and then you
can prove that you that they match
exactly the NBR bound I
I don't have a slide on it but there are
some really really beautiful
constructions actually so the four for
this point okay now the one problem I
guess is we don't have a lot of
constructions for the intermediate
region and and we don't even know the
intermediate region okay so that's the
first prom second problem because I need
to wrap up open road number two for the
MSR point for the minimum storage point
which means MDS codes all known exact
minimum storage constructions require
exponential field size and exponential
sub packetization in fact there are
three constructions that were
concurrently done in 2012 one of them by
my group the harder Marco does we were
calling it kodama designs i guess a
number and tommo had concurrent and all
these three constructions we think are
basically almost equivalent but the the
thermo construction has a benefit if
there's only two parties then she has a
small field but in general we don't have
any way of doing polynomial field size
and polynomials and packetization 4ms r
codes furthermore ok so there are some
practical constructions that that are
not that are not optimal one of them is
the piggyback paper that appeared in
sikkim this year the other important
thing about this paper is that that they
actually implemented it in Hadoop which
is a very hard thing to do I can
guarantee you that so that is that was a
practical construction that is the
closest I guess we have to to an
implementable minimum storage region
code and the the main open problem i
think here is can we approach or even
possibly match the minimum storage point
with polynomial some packetization so
that it's actually code that that people
in facebook you know can can use so
that's a that's an important open
problem here other any questions on this
and another open problem that i think is
embarrassing a little bit is what's the
best info communication for edit solomon
code right so that's like classic object
how much information do you need to
communicate to reconstruct obviously you
cannot construct a symbol by
communicating case symbols right can you
do it with less yes so we have a paper
in in 2012 that if you mess around but
you remember to do it with less you have
to hack the field right you have to send
half filled things so you have to define
what the hell that means so you open the
field and you look at the field and use
and you there's a few ways you can do
that so you need to create a linear
algebra so to speak in the subfields and
and we do that and I guess I guess
people who work with extension fields
could think about it in different ways
to but we have just one construction
that improves over the trivial thing of
sending k symbols observation in order
to have any hope of benefit you need to
connect to more than K nodes right so if
you connect to any k you communicate
case symbols and you repair now in order
to in there generating codes if you want
to get a benefit you have to connect to
more than K and get smaller things from
each and now the same question can hold
for any family of codes like the moolah
if i know'd etcetera how do you repair
these codes even even a non-trivial
scheme for repairing a little moolah for
example i think is open for even though
there is one construction so that's not
another important open from now the last
thing is for for tomorrow's lecture i'll
just say everything i said so far was on
the number of bits that are communicated
in the network during a single failure
that's called reverb and there are these
two other metrics that practitioners
tell me that are important one of them
is the number of bits that you read from
the disks during repair which can be
different and the other one is the
number of nodes that you access to
repair that's called locality that
that's that's the previous tutorial so
for this problem basically we don't know
the capacity I had the congestion the
capacity that was disproved as I said we
only know some points for this problem I
don't think we know a lot
things that are non-trivial so it's it's
quite a wide open problem and for this
problem we know the capacity for most
cases i guess that Tamil bug is the
state of the art for this for codes also
that have small finite field which I
think are working for most parameters as
long as there's a polynomial a constant
polynomial that can be constructed
there's there's a technical issue there
so in the next lecture I will talk about
this problem and and some extensions of
that and I will stop here any other
questions I think a very important
question is what what are you offering
12 bottles of who's on it for next yeah
good question I I let me think about it
and maybe maybe tomorrow I'll i can i
can do something yeah it might want an
upgraded price as well yeah that's a
good that's a good question yes so so
this MDS conjecture was proven in the
prime case actually says it not just
that you say a calculation of the
optimal code sets an optimal codes are
in some sense equivalent oh you'll eat
Solomon do you have some such
conjectures for this type of codes
optimal course of just one solution
unique solution no I think we know much
less much much less about this problem
are than than than for the MDS the I
mean the related question in this
problem is what's the minimum field
where you can perform exactly pair if
even in fact even if you do functional
repair which is basically multi casting
it's open right a minimum field for I
don't know I mean I maybe knows this
better what's the postman if I give you
a multi casting problem the smallest
field size that you can create a
multicast code is open right yes
general with something so far if you
have only two sources then we know and
have a tight bound and everything that's
sort of timing errors and in one
direction we kind of direct it
immediately focus another year to find
us ah but when you have a end it's not
we still that it's bare root of n as in
two cases that we are not sure and then
it becomes like the arc problem in the
alphabet size except that now in
discrete Solomon you may have some zeros
for respect may be late but actually I'm
thinking about it now I can't even tell
you much more embarrassing situation I
don't even know if I I need exponential
field size yeah so I don't know so I
don't have I don't know how to construct
I don't know a single code for this
point exactly pair that needs polynomial
field size yeah am I miss me miss me
yeah okay oh yeah something interesting
there is if you are okay with rate
greater than half saree rate less oh yes
yes sure you can do it in quadratic feel
safe but as soon as you cross the half
barrier the node construction big lower
yeah yeah very good yeah so this there's
a distinction here if / rates below half
there are very many practical
construction is the product matrix and
the eigen and the eigenvector
construction are the two that are very
neat and and practical but but for high
rate codes rather than half which i
think is that they think the case where
many people in starts care about a lot
we don't have anything so yes very good
ya see this metal said and he said the
Sun you're forcing some zeros new year
so acquired some determinants are
nonzero Anderson with a random the
scientist sort of you taken to the unit
part of all possible things and it is a
bed like you it's not exactly that the
same way you prove like further if you
try to create a an MDS code which is
random you just get a hit exponential
field size so can we do better and in
for MDS you can read Solomon
for this problem I don't know yeah so
but there was a question exactly aligns
to you why yes ya know ya beating k for
Rick Sullivan how much we we did by the
very little very little asymptotically
asymptotic leave early so if we
basically we have a decent benefit when
n minus K is constant so for a constant
number of parties we get something but
but okay or is it k by 2 oh hey i don't
i don't know how it asymptotes to be how
it vanishes but definitely if your code
has constant rate and n NK grow it
vanishes the benefit vanishes I don't I
don't I haven't figured out how but yeah
yeah what's up Alex and so into
practically speaking and with so I I
could the sort of argument with Sergey
yesterday cuz kekeke also deliver field
size was important to me i don't
understand i mean your codes practically
I mean facebook has gone not going to
use n equals million ever right it's
always going to be like a few hundred
maybe so so why not you I mean you can
implement in hardware very cheaply to
264 few yeah so okay so this fair enough
so so I'll tell ya so first of all n so
there's many things right so this block
length there's some packetization feel
sighs okay now a field size I can make
if I store bites like the current Hadoop
thing raid HDFS raid uses bites so
you're working with with 22 v8 you can't
convince them to go to to to the 16 22
the 32 you I don't think you can
convince them to go above that because
they it will be a pain to to implement
and performance wise and all that so I
think that's the field let the big much
bigger problem than the field size
itself is the supply cute ization
because it's a regulation you have to
have logic that deals with the sub
packets and if they are you know a
thousand which is not a big number then
you will have a lot of pain so I think
the packetization is a bigger problem
than than feel sighs it's [ __ ] also
from the big feel like this is something
which came up buddy yeah the
coefficients the coefficients will come
can come from I think to do this but the
sub pocket size is is is you can make
them big if you want to buy growing them
in this direction right so ok so just
clarify something year old anyway yeah
so if you have big blocks you can even
with binary you can make them big by
repeating the same code so that's fine
now you need a little bit of power in
your field so you group the bits in
terms of two or pairs of eight and you
work that's how you make the field
bigger so your blocks can be 64
megabytes but your field size one symbol
is not 64 megabytes right so you Oh can
always repeat the code and that's that's
how you go to bigger things the things
they don't like is n NK being bigger
than 20 or 30 or 40 because for many
reasons overheads keeping track of
blocks and and also they don't like sub
pockets I think being a lot because they
have to keep track of sub pockets in
metadata and I think the metadata
storage explodes because their story you
know billions of billions of files so
yeah so I think the packetized as to the
best of my understanding practically a
[ __ ] ization is a biggest issue than
field size but field size ridiculous
field size above 2 to the 32 I think
would also make it impractical something
in geometry that we don't understand
somehow that's why would be nice to
solve yeah I mean fundamentally yeah so
there's as many worlds right so but for
both I think this is an interesting
question
good that you had time left at the end
because you got a lot of good questions
in the discussion that's that's always a
good thing thank you very much he I was
a great time